all right before we get to videoing and
reviewing I do want to thank the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by Sony's a5000 Dolby Atmos Soundbar
the next level of audio immersion but
with the optional subwoofer and Surround
speakers now you're leveling up the
optional subwoofer and rear speakers
uses 360 spatial sound mapping the
system Maps out the room in the speaker
positioning allowing you to place the
rear speakers in the most convenient
location and I do mean convenient the
rear speakers have a rechargeable
battery making them Wireless keep them
plugged in if you want or when they have
that charge you put them
anywhere no speaker wires going anywhere
I like that they connect easily with
Bluetooth and I do mean easily it's
pretty plug and play all of this I bring
to you in the name of that life's
journey that quest to achieve that
theatrical audio experience at home just
because you watch movies at home doesn't
mean you should have to compromise bring
that theatrical experience home with you
I say so click the link below to check
out the a5000 Soundbar an optional
expanded system save yourself 300 bucks
on Sony's a5000 Soundbar and now
do you remember when a Disney animated
feature film was an event I sure
[Music]
do so wish is Disney's new animated
feature film also the film that's going
to celebrate 100 Years of Disney which
means yes this is what happens when a
company that has no idea what people
want sets out to give people what they
the company think the people want our
main character Asha resides in a kingdom
that's ruled by this sorcerer King
named what's his name magnifico I was
like what's his name orgasmos it's not
that magnifico collects the dreams of
the masses with the promise that he
might Grant one of The Wishes one day I
appreciate that the movie shows
intermittent reinforcement is a very
effective tool of manipulation it's
actually a really solid Disney allegory
that I feel like they accidentally made
cuz that is why the people who keep
watching Disney animated movies keep
watching Disney animated movies maybe
one day it'll come true maybe one day
will be as good as it once was and well
that hope keeps people engaged she
wishes upon a star that star becomes one
of the Lumas from Mario and now she's on
a quest to essentially expose the fraud
that's running the kingdom which on
paper sounds solid now the art style of
this animation I thought was creative in
concept anyway it's this animated style
that looks like it throws back to
handdrawn animation but is done on a
computer with a conversation of this
film of oh wish is coming out in the
year of Disney celebrating 100 years
felt that is a creative way conceptually
speaking to celebrate that that said
it's all about how you put it in motion
for your animated feature film and put
in motion a lot of this movie feels dull
boring Bland and lifeless to be honest
with you in a world of bland forgettable
characters in this film I felt Chris
Pine is magnifico I thought he was fun
he's pretty mustache twirly villain it's
overcooked a little bit his animation is
it's more emotive it's more expressive
in that exact exaggerated way than
anyone else in the film everyone else is
kind of like okay yeah I talk like this
magnifico's animated 9s villain all like
yes but what do you want felt like
magnifico and the rest of the movie were
pulled from two very different decades
but the point is that was the character
that was the most fun I mean villain
villains are usually a little more fun
also the support characters I do not
remember a single name if we're looking
at Disney themed buddies you have a
little goat who talks
and like I said the little star that
becomes a Luma from Mario I liked a
little goat to a point any dog owner is
going to be like that reminds me of my
dog and then the goat starts talking and
as much as we all love Alan tudk just
wasn't as interesting to me I like the
fact that I got what the goat was
feeling when he wasn't even talking that
is a strength of Disney's past having
characters who don't talk but you still
know what they're feeling the little
Luma star doesn't talk maybe they felt
they needed one of the little buddy
creatures to talk though I would use
carpet and Abu two characters who didn't
talk who were in the same movie as a
counter example well to be fair abuk
kind of talked granted you had Robin
Williams as the genie that's not a side
character that's Robin Williams making
it his movie didn't help that the jokes
didn't land oh good find Valentino my
butt found it Devil's Advocate this
movie is not made for me it's made for
children counterargument when I was a
kid eating up Disney animations my
parents loved them too that's the
difference between a movie that's made
for kids and made for families families
including adults but it all really does
boil down to do you have a Synergy in
your film do you feel the connection
with the side characters in the main
character do they feel like friends or
family her boring group of friends I
will call them useless more importantly
I didn't feel the Friendship they were
buddies you know the difference there
are people we know in our lives those
friends that you can count the number on
one hand and you are friends to the end
then there are those people you know
friendly acquaintances that you describe
as buddies you know like oh yeah a buddy
told me that's what this group of
friends feels like it's the Buddies the
people that maybe she'll know a year
from now now maybe she won't but I
myself when watching a movie like this I
would like to at least feel a deeper
connection than that at this point it's
I just feel like a couple years from now
they're all going to lose contact and
their lives will be no better or worse
for it and it being a Disney animated
Adventure has its music I mean the
music's fine one song in particular I
felt stood Out Among the other ones it
just had a good beat it had good drums
rest of it was you know it was all right
no one's going to go out of their way to
be like I [__] need the soundtrack
it's what happens with the convenience
of Spotify maybe you'll listen to it on
a streaming service for free or
something but ask yourself would you
really pay money for the soundtrack no
one's going to do that also with
memberberries you have all those
memberberries you think Disney and South
Parker and Cahoots you think Disney's
like hey we'll do content you talk about
it in turn we'll get us in the chatter
of people online like do you think
they're working together you think
Disney's trying really hard to validate
South Park cuz my God you would think
there's an effort there case in point
the member berries in this movie you see
references and characters from Disney
movies of the past maybe if that wasn't
the norm in entertainment right now I'd
be seeing it through different lenses
maybe I would think it was a fun
celebration but at this point it's so
overdone I'm just sick of it and it
again shows the mindset of what is
celebration for Disney in 2023 for such
a celebration you know that conversation
being a big part of the marketing of the
movie I would think you would want to
make an animated Adventure that is Peak
that shows why why you've been around
for a hundred years not references to
the movies of the past and that's that
this movie feels like it was written by
Disney cheating off of its own test like
it's the day of the essays due at zero
hour but Disney didn't do the homework
so current Disney has to cheat off of
the essay of past Disney but has to put
it in their own words you know so they
don't get caught for plagiarism also
current Disney doesn't understand the
heart and soul of that kind of passion
so it just comes across as robotic it
didn't feel like a celebration of 100
Years of Disney it felt like a
celebration of the H hundredth year of
of Disney and that's what it is a very
safe very sterile Adventure sprinkled
with member berries that most anybody
can watch but no one's going to love and
I'm not going to remember it in T-minus
one day yep already forgot all right so
wish have you seen it are you going to
see it or what's your favorite Disney
animated Adventure whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see
[Music]
more